[Musique]
ben sentir en échec à regarder la vie
passée les chaînes ses portes
chérie tu te souviens de kevin au kit
cfoot a pas changé alors tu comptes
faire quoi que tu t'es fait virer qu'on
ait connu j'ai commencé un travail
temporaire dans une société de relations
publiques
vous avez toujours su que c'était ça que
vous vouliez faire ou vous aviez envie
de faire autre chose au départ
genre je rêvais de faire du patinage
artistique mais mes parents n'ont pas
voulu me payer les cours ne voulais pas
rester intérimaire toute votre vie
les kits j'ai une lettre pour toi
[Musique]
tu es par toi je dois me préparer pour
quoi
[Musique]
il ya un venu au magasin quitte je suis
le vendeur du magasin
amer ici nous vendons ce dont tu as
besoin et lille corps c'est la seule
chose dont j'ai toujours rêvé pour faire
venir une licorne jusqu'ici j'ai besoin
de savoir si tu es vraiment motivés
[Musique]
j'ai pris une décision construire une
maison qui souhaitent signé de votre
corps je pensais y que je crois pas
qu'un poney aurait envie de vivre dans
son sous-sol simpana remarque tu es en
train de nous faire une place tu veux
contacter chat est un bébé chien je sais
que je suis une grande déception vous
dit toujours pourquoi tu as peut être
comparé à tous pourquoi tu pas puisque
kevin quelqu'un m'a appelé non je sais
pas comment être l'adulte mes parents on
pense que j'étais folle on aimerait que
tu nous dis ce qui se passe vraiment toi
c'est complètement de la chose la plus
adulte qu'on puisse faire c'est
d'échouer sur ce qui nous tient vraiment
à coeur
licorne thème rapporte toujours
dépêche-toi montre nous ce que tu as
fait l'addition
il a déchiré
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde a besoin de magie dans sa
vie même quand on a atteint l'âge adulte
et cette licorne elle vient d'où
hécatombe des magasins de l'école oh oui
[Musique]